what's up everybody we're punk Finity  and today we're gonna play table tennis  with a dog  this is thira she's going to be our  guest star in this episode  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  let's play there Pyrrha can be a bulldog  [Music]  [Applause]  hi  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  it's time for Tara to show her tables  and skills let's see what she's got  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  Oh  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  back  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  thanks for watching guys hope you  enjoyed this video if you want to see  more videos with Peter but Ableton s dog  leave this video a thumbs up until next  time  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]